es un palacio de la ciencia ha perdido
en medio de la selva a dos horas en
lancha rápida desde quizá cani el centro
de investigación de yangambi se revela
en medio de la cubierta forestal
bordeado por el majestuoso río con
alrededor una reserva de la biósfera de
más de 250.000 hectáreas este es el
campo de juego de néstor language
investigador de la universidad de
kisangani y del museo real de áfrica
central quien turbulent en bélgica a
freddy a metro es ese 45.5 junto con su
ayudante en esto controla el diámetro de
cada árbol y toma muestras con este
taladro que introduce en el tronco
sacamos nuestras todos los meses nos
permite saber en qué mes está creciendo
el árbol y en qué mes está descansando
aquel mucho oleaje en su laboratorio en
esto él analiza las muestras luego
observa con el microscopio los anillos
de crecimiento es decir la madera que el
árbol forma cada año a medida que crece
su datación esta adaptación de los
árboles nos permite en realidad
comprender cuánto tiempo tarda el bosque
en alcanzar el nivel o la estructura que
tiene hoy
si cortamos el bosque hoy sabemos que
para volver a tenerlo tendremos que
esperar otros tantos años no salvo que
su labor hong kong y fondo atando otan
dan fundado por los belgas en 1933 el
centro de yangambi fue en su día la
mayor estación de investigación tropical
del mundo y desde entonces rebautizado
como inr a instituto nacional de
estudios e investigaciones agronómicas
hoy en día los antiguos edificios
coloniales han perdido su antiguo
esplendor pero siguen contenidos tesoros
de incalculable valor
este es el mayor de áfrica central con
150 mil especies de plantas catalogadas
y ha sobrevivido milagrosamente a
guerras y saqueos
tenemos rebeldes que vinieron aquí y
preguntaron qué hay aquí es de las
plantas
es todo lo que hay aquí les parece
ridículo secos y así sobrevivió sí
porque la gente no lo entendía pensaba
que era algo que no se podía vender con
paypal de ron a pesar del regreso de la
paz el herbario sigue amenazado la
humedad puede dañar parte de la
colección para preservarlo y nera y un
equipo del jardín botánico de meis en
bélgica pusieron en marcha en 2018 un
programa de digitalización de los
ejemplares tenemos la imagen así que
podemos buscar en la web podemos verlo
incluso si ocurriera un accidente ojalá
nunca pase al menos habremos salvado la
imagen
un poco más allá yangambi contiene otro
tesoro su biblioteca más de 300.000
libros y documentos que solo se pueden
encontrar aquí y que siguen siendo
utilizados por los científicos en la
actualidad
tenemos por ejemplo los detalles
climatológicos que se han recogido desde
la época colonial hasta la actualidad
sin interrupción
estos datos pueden trazar la historia
del clima
si queremos impulsarnos hacia el futuro
tenemos que basarnos primero en el
pasado o conservas la boards
[Música]
abandonada desde hace varias décadas la
estación de investigación de ya gaby
está reviviendo poco a poco gracias a la
movilización de científicos y donantes
internacionales como la ong sifón y la
unión europea entre las últimas
inversiones esta torre de flujo la
primera en la cuenca del congo a 55
metros de altura mide los intercambios
de gases entre el bosque y la atmósfera
emanuel balanza sube a los 11 pisos cada
semana para comprobar que el equipo
funciona correctamente
vale conexión perfecta introduce los
detalles aquí utilizamos un dispositivo
que trata de medir la velocidad y la
dirección del viento en las tres
direcciones y luego hay otra máquina o
dispositivo que mide la cantidad de co2
es decir la concentración y con los
programas informáticos entendamos
combinarlos combina la selva de la
cuenca del congo es el segundo bosque
tropical más grande del mundo y el
segundo pulmón verde del planeta después
del amazonas pero en 20 años el bosque
primario que rodea a janvey se ha
reducido en casi un 25 por ciento
con el tiempo podría emitir más co2 del
que absorbe no puedo decir que
conscientes o no pero mi papel si tengo
que decirlo es decir a la población aquí
está nuestra riqueza no podemos
conservar este bosque
para los científicos la preservación del
bosque requiere un diálogo con la
población local hombres y mujeres que
obtienen sus recursos y su sustento de
la biosfera
el sistema aquí era la agricultura de
tala y quema llegamos a un bosque
natural cortamos los árboles les
prendemos fuego y sembramos una vez
después de la cosecha se le emboscando
nuevas tierras así que les dijimos que
no existe la posibilidad de volver a
atestiguar varias veces en el mismo ya
pasó a darme más paz en la era del
cambio climático el reto es crucial
proteger el medio ambiente al tiempo que
se ayuda a las personas a encontrar
medios de vida alternativos como con
este horno natural que duplica la
producción de carbón utilizando la misma
cantidad de madera
sólo podemos crecer con los recursos que
tenemos pero en cambio estamos que saber
controlar el recurso para satisfacer
nuestras necesidades y permitir que el
recurso se rellene al dólar entonces se
regenere una lección que está más
vigente que nunca casi un siglo después
de su creación
yangambi no ha terminado de concientizar
a la gente